the federal government releasing its
first gun crime report in more than two
decades and the numbers are without
question quite High it also goes into
detail on the type of guns being used
during crimes Joshua peguero Joins us
live in studio with a breakdown Joshua
now the the this map from the Bureau of
Alcohol Tobacco firearms and explosives
shows where authorities recovered the
most guns in our area without a serial
number these guns were used in crimes
and as you can see the highest
concentration is in the South Central
Valley
the ATF says Glock 9 millimeter pistols
are most commonly used in Las Vegas
crimes the ATF seized 17 000 over a
five-year period from 2017 to 2021 about
a third of guns have less than a year of
time to Crime that's the time from when
they were bought to when they were used
in crimes but the biggest takeaway the
ATF calling stolen guns an epidemic with
more than a million stolen around the
country nearly all from private owners
Jonathan Alvarez is with Crime Stoppers
of Nevada he says people don't often
secure their weapons most of the time
when we're our security officers are out
in the field and we uh we get you know
contacted for missing items things like
that are missing Firearms or firearms
that were stolen it always has to do
with improper storage of the Firearms
representative Dina Titus tells us in a
statement quote I'm working with both
parties in Congress to arrest this
disturbing trend of gun violence and ban
the tools of mass Shooters authorities
say these people are often too
embarrassed to report the gun has stolen
so the ATF data may not be as accurate
still Alvarez says owning a gun comes
with tremendous responsibility people
just leave them in the in their vehicles
unattended they just put it under the
floorboard or within their center
console or glove compartment and that's
not a safe secure area
now atf's report also shows that if the
stolen goods were covered in the valley
70 percent stayed in the silver state
but the other third ended up in
California mostly in Los Angeles and
Oakland Brian